I'm Susan Barrett I'm the director of
the world chess Hall of Fame and it's my
honor to welcome all you international
chess enthusiasts and future chess
enthusiasts we have people here who've
traveled here from Chicago New York
Newark Philly Boston Salt Lake City
Tempe Arizona Charlotte Reno and Fort
Worth but we also have represented
Mexico City Rome nice war club :
Frankfurt and Dusseldorf
so it's really an international event so
thank you very much this could not have
been possible but without Rex and Jeanne
sing fields vision and generosity so
without further ado we will get to all
of you're here tonight to help us
celebrate the opening of the world chess
Hall of Fame which we hope will bring
visitors from all over the world and
further solidify st. Louis as a
certainly a national center and maybe
someday a world center of chess it's a
great day
this is gonna be a great day a landmark
for the city of st. Louis and someday
you're right wax it is gonna be the
world's center of chess so on behalf of
the st. Louis County
welcome to the greater metropolitan area
and let's have a great time tonight
thank you
hi I'm Shannon Bailey I'm the vice
president of exhibition and curatorial
Affairs and we're at the world chess
Hall of Fame our first floor exhibit is
called out of the box artists play chess
and it features the work of Tom Friedman
Lily Olaf ANOVA Barbara Kruger Yoko Ono
Gavin Turk Diana fader and Guiteau van
der bear one of the most intriguing
pieces in this show that we've heard so
much feedback is the Laila fauna Bose
piece which is called Anatomy is destiny
and it is really intriguing to see this
very monumental piece with a 16 by 16
square foot chess board it has these 32
costumes hanging from the ceiling that
have this relationship to chess pieces
and military uniforms and what's really
intriguing about the piece is that we
have the installation here but it's
really part of a performance that will
be taking place at the Contemporary Art
Museum later this winter that will be
hosting and Lily will be back in st.
Louis to help make that project happen
our second floor gallery features the
exhibition chess masterpieces highlights
from the dr. George and Vivian Diamond
Collection
my name is Larry list I'm the consulting
curator responsible for this exhibition
it's one of the inaugural exhibitions
here at the world chess Hall of Fame in
st. Louis what we're looking at is 30
incredibly rare and unique chess sets
that span from 900 AD in Persia to 1924
in the Soviet Union
Larry Liszt who was the curator
a wonderful job we worked in tandem over
the past year he visited us in our home
and I've in New York I visited with him
and he we chose these sets and he's
displayed them magnificently my wife and
I have been collecting just sets for 50
years we've managed to collect over a
thousand test sets and test items
through the years from a hundred
different countries and what we have on
exhibition here are 30 of those sets and
some of them are very important and very
beautiful and I hope that everybody who
comes to visit will appreciate that
chess sets can be an art form it can be
very beautiful it works about 32 pieces
of miniature sculpture we are on the
third floor which is our US and world
chess Hall of Fame's this floor as
you'll be able to see has our US Hall of
Fame plaques as well as our world chess
Hall of Fame plaque and we also feature
highlights from the permanent collection
yesterday we saw Harold Winston induct
three new members into the 2011 halls of
fame for the u.s. we had Boris cocoa and
Andy Soltis and for the world we had
barometric by the authority vested in me
we welcome you to visit us we're located
at 46:52 Maryland Avenue in the Central
West End and you can find out more
information about us at wwl just hof go
RG